Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
Today's video is like nothing you ever bought at IKEA.
It comes to you in only two parts.
Part One: Commencing
So, over the weekend, Sarah and I drove to Gambier, Ohio
Where I got to deliver the commencement address
at my Alma mater, Kenyon College.
Here's part of what I said:
So, when I was a student here, uh,
There was widespread agreement among my peers
That the so called "real world of proper adulthood"
was basically a disease you caught
and then eventually died from.
(audience laughter)
Like, adulthood, with its mortgages,
and spreadsheets and lawn maintenance seemed to be a thing
to be dreaded
and resisted, until finally, it overtook you
like a zombie plague.
(slight audience laughter)
And then, like, once you acquired adulthood,
you would start saying things like "brand awareness
in a fractured media landscape."
(audience laughter)
and "we need a president who knows how to get things done."
To be an adult meant engaging in totally unironic
conversations about the weather.
(audience laughter)
I remember once when I was at Kenyon,
my grandmother called me to tell me that she was
watching the Weather Channel and that it looked like it was raining
in Ohio
(audience laughter)
I explained to her that I was reading Ulysses
That I wasn't even in Gambier,
but in Dublin, Ireland in 1904
and that history was a nightmare from which
Dedalus was trying to awake
and that nothing,
literally nothing
mattered less than the current weather.
(audience laughter)
and then after a moment she asked,
"Well, is it raining, or isn't it?"
(audience laughter)
To be an adult was to be a river rock
blasted by an endless torrent of mundane terrors,
from resume formatting,
to electricity bills
that would inevitably smooth all my hard edges
until I looked and felt just like everything else.
Now, this is the part of the commencement address
where I'm supposed to tell you that it in fact,
adulthood isn't so bad and
blah, blah, blah,
but no, no, it is so bad! (audience laughter)
side note: graduation gowns are not flattering.
In the end, the speech is mostly just a celebration
of unironic conversations about the weather
If you want to watch or read the whole thing,
you can do so. Links in the doobly doo.
Part Two: sports.
So, Hank, I'm in the midst of the greatest sports month of my life.
A couple weeks ago, I drove the pace car
at the Indianapolis Grand Prix
which allowed me to experience what it's like to be
tailgated by thirty professional race car drivers.
We're just six days away from the annual
highlight of my social calendar,
the Indianapolis 500
and most amazingly, the fourth tier English
football team, Nerdfighteria sponsors
AFC Wimbledon have found themselves
in the playoff finals, just one victory away
from being a third tier English football team.
That's right, Hank, on May 30th, AFC Wimbledon
will take the field at Wembley, a 90,000
seat stadium, and wearing DFTBA
on the back of their shorts,
they will play a one game playoff against
The Sailing Ships of Plymouth Argyle
It's hard to describe how unlikely this is,
Wimbledon have the smallest stadium of any team in their league,
and among the smallest budgets.
They'd also be the only English team owned by their fans
to be as high as the third tier,
so this is a massive moment for the club,
and, as you know if you listen to our podcast
where you can get all the week's news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
I am immensely excited!
In fact Hank, I am leaving directly from the Indianapolis 500
to go to the game in London.
So Nerdfighters, if you live in or near London, I hope
you'll come to Wembley on May 30th to cheer on the Dons
If you want to go to the game but can't afford a ticket,
Email me and I will try to work something out
Info on all of that in the doobly doo
Hank, I know that sports are silly.
But as Pope John Paul II once said:
"Of all the unimportant things, football is the most important."
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.